let's give it up to Jen Rubio the
founder and she's going to tell us their
story the world is yours so what we're
going to do is Jen and I are going to
have a little conversation here where
I'm going to ask some questions and I've
actually asked some of you in the
audience what you guys think and I've
got a bunch of questions from everyone
but uh we're just have a little bit of a
conversation here let's start it off Jen
what's interesting is that luggage isn't
particularly a sexy industry to start in
it is now it is now but it was it why
why start a luggage company and why
start there yeah so we started working
on this in January of 2015 and we like
to say we have a thoughtful luggage
brand not a smart luggage brand and at
the core of what we're doing is pretty
simple we're a direct-to-consumer
company that sells one product which are
the rolling suitcases that you see here
and when we started working on this it
was a time when there was you know a lot
of like everyone was making all of their
home goods and objects smart you know
there's like a big push in the internet
of things and we just decide to take a
step back and take a little bit of a
different approach it basically started
with my luggage broke and I was like
asking my friends for recommendations
and they're just like wasn't anything
out there that anyone was really
passionate about like you said it's just
not really like a sexy thing to think
about you know people love thinking
about travel but they don't actually
want to think about what they're packing
there's stuff in and everything out
there was either really like cheap and
flimsy or super expensive and cost a
thousand dollars for a suitcase if
you've ever been in a luggage store
probably looks something like this the
luggage buying experience just
completely sucked and we knew they're
just like had to be a better way so what
we did is we Dobin did a ton of consumer
research like focus groups we just like
sit in people's houses and watch them
pack just really creepy now that I think
about it
but we really just got to the core of
how people travel what their pain points
are what they really need in a suitcase
and that's how we came out with you know
the one perfect suitcase for everyone
everything you need nothing you don't
and is last year we launched with really
just one suitcase it just came in a
carry-on size and four colors and it
only had one like tech enabled feature
which is a USB charger built into the
bag to charge your devices while you're
on the go and what's interesting what is
interesting is that so you came from
Warby Parker which they did something
almost kind of similar where they took
glasses which is incredibly sexy and
they made the brand extremely sexy and
really cool and everyone wants a pair of
Warby Parker's luggage is the same thing
it's pretty boring not a lot of people
really like you don't exactly Instagram
your new luggage but you guys have
somehow managed to get people to give a
about something that was typically
so boring and people love this and so
how did you don't get a lot of shits now
so Shep how did you define your brand
early on yeah so I mean I think you know
context is everything
we started out you know they start out
with an idea for a luggage company but
really early on we realized there's just
a huge gap in the travel space you know
everyone loves going on vacation taking
trips but the actual companies involved
in the travel space pretty much suck
from a brand perspective whether it's
like you know they just don't care about
the experience and there's just a big
gap for a brand that thinks and talks
about travel and experiences the way we
travel the way a lot of you people in
the audience probably like to travel and
who care more about experiences and
things and readings and reviews and
that's kind of how we thought about
starting the company and we just we
wanted to build a travel brand and we
started with luggage and you know since
we've launched we've kind of been called
you know what is the holy grail of
marketing buzzwords a lifestyle brand
and it's because from day one we've
really thought about context and
storytelling if you think about other
luggage companies out there
they'll have imagery that's all about
zippers and wheels and materials and
doesn't give you any context on what
this luggage is supposed to help you do
better or what it enables you to do so
from day one we wanted to take a
different approach even if it was just
starting with our first photo shoot and
our imagery which you can see here
there's also you know in terms of
starting a lifestyle brand
the first product we ever sold wasn't
actually luggage it was this book so we
knew back in November 2015 having work
for direct to consumer brands and
fashion brands that holiday was you know
a big moment that we didn't want to miss
the holidays were coming up we knew
there are a lot of like big press
moments we wanted to hit and they're
just the luggage just wasn't ready you
know we're working with our factory and
they're making it as fast as they could
but we didn't want to rush that process
so we thought to ourselves how do we get
in front of all these people how do we
get into these gift guides that we know
like would make a huge impact on our
business and how do we do it without you
know crowdfunding or we're doing
pre-orders you know because we wanted to
be a brand and not just like a one-hit
product it very much wasn't part of our
strategy it works for some people it's
not something B wanted to do so we did
what probably all of you would do in
here we decided to write and publish our
own book and we we hired a writer we
interviewed 40 influencers and these
were celebrities or household names that
people at the top of their field in
fashion and art in music in food
interviewer interviewed them about you
know about travel the book is called the
places we've returned to we packaged it
up and this beautiful gift set and we
sold it for two hundred and twenty-five
dollars and inside there was a gift card
for our luggage that was set to launch
in a few months so we're like okay this
is either brilliant or just a really
weird convoluted idea and definitely not
going to work but that Christmas we were
in over a hundred gift guides and all
the top publications you know it was the
perfect gift for every traveler in your
life and we sold out of thousands of the
books and gift cards in a few weeks
before our luggage had even launched and
speaking of starting out so to give
everyone the full perspective here so
you guys what we're around for about a
year when you were tinkering with the
idea and testing and then you raised the
seed round like about 15 months ago and
starting around that time I started
noticing that you guys were in a ton of
different outlets and you were a lot of
journalists are writing about you can
you talk more about how you're able to
get all this press so early into the
company yeah definitely it's just about
you know I think having a great product
isn't enough to keep the good press
going I think we were really lucky we
had really solid PR and press around our
lodge but someone can only write about
the suitcase ones before it gets really
boring so once we kind of got in all the
big publications we realized very
quickly but you have to consider every
single moment a storytelling moment so
you know one example of that is a couple
of months after we launched we started
thinking about launching monogramming
which is pretty standard offering when
it comes to luggage you know just
putting your initials on your bag and
we're thinking about okay how do we make
this a press moment so we hired three
brooklyn-based artists who did all of
their own like monogramming styles and
for one month only we said that we were
going to offer monograms hand-painted by
these artists in our studio
the New York Times wanted an exclusive
on this story all the fashion magazines
picked up on it and here we were I mean
if you really think about the concept we
did not we did not optimize for
scalability or or operational ease you
can just ask their office team who still
hates me but we we optimized for the
story and for something that people
would talk about we actually tried to
end this after a month
but it was in such high demand from
editors from influencers from customers
that to this day we now have a
hand-painted monogramming studio in New
York with like a
than artists just painting initials on
bags all day long and that's just
thinking about you know what are the
features that you guys are putting out
there and can you make it a bigger story
around that can you make it more
exciting it doesn't have to be something
that that that you build out with your
company as we did with monogramming but
but it's definitely a big part of
something that it gives people something
to talk about another huge part of our
growth has been collaboration so you
know we're lucky travel the field where
that spans across different industries
and what we do is we look into each of
these verticals that we want to hit who
have who have people that we want to
engage with and we find you know kind of
the best people and the best companies
to work with that have loyal engaged
audiences this year these are a few
collapse from the beginning of this year
we launched a pink suitcase with Suki
Waterhouse and papi Jaime's accessories
line we did a suitcase for charity:water
we launched one with made well just this
week we did a yellow suitcase for
Despicable Me 3 which was which is
actually an inbound request from the
studio because they'd seen all the other
collaborations we've done and I think at
the core of it you know it's great these
collabs all of these collabs have sold
out within a few days but what we really
see is just to spread an awareness so
even if someone's not going to buy a
yellow suitcase or a pink suitcase they
see the press people are talking about
it and we actually see sales of our
number-one products which is a navy
carry-on go up when we launch these
collaborations some other press-worthy
moments we use a lot of data to find
kind of these key business moments for
our company
so luggage is a big there's a big
gifting moment in luggage for holidays
for birthdays and we decided to
capitalize on that in a really brand
lead way so we actually now with an
in-house editorial team for this
Father's Day wrote another book got a
lot of influential dads talking
about their trips as fathers for the
first time or with their fathers
published it in the book we partnered
with Harry's to provide a shave set for
every piece of luggage purchase for
Father's Day again tons of gift guides
tons of press like big events like lots
of mentions from influencers perfect
Father's Day gift and its really
capitalizing on those moments that that
we know as a business work for us but
but without we need to make a little
more exciting for our consumers and then
lastly on that and I think there's a lot
of kind of big cultural events whether
it's know South by Southwest Coachella
this is from Art Basel in Miami and I
think you know a lot of a lot of
companies think that you need huge
marketing budgets to go to those events
and be relevant when we decided to go to
Art Basel in Miami last year admittedly
we didn't really have you know the
experience or the connections or the
budgets to come in and make a huge
splash the way a traditional company
would but we did know two things we knew
that there would be cool people there
and we knew that their phones would die
so we built this bicycle charging
station we parked it around you know
kind of the best parties and people were
talking about it and I was like a pretty
low cost super effective way to get
people talking about something it was
more effective than just putting like a
charger and a gift bag and way more
effective than just throwing a big party
with our logo on it but if you kind of
take utility and then create a moment
that's cool enough for people to talk
about they will and basically if
storytelling is what's driving you and
your business and your activations it
means that people were right about it
people are right about your company your
product your tactics yourself we've been
lucky enough to be in hundreds and
hundreds of top-tier publications in
less than two years are a lot of our
growth can be attributed to
word-of-mouth and earn media and and you
know and we don't take that for granted
we know that if we just kind of stop
what we're doing there really won't be
anything to write about so it's just
thinking about how can you make your
company into something that
people will want to talk about when
they're when they're out to dinner with
their friends and you didn't have a PR
team for that did you
we did so actually that was one of the
biggest investments that we made early
on we knew that even before we spent a
dollar on like paid marketing we we knew
that we wanted to find you know kind of
great PR agency to partner with we drove
our strategy in-house and kind of
decided on what stories we would tell
and then use a PR agency to seed those
two they're kind of editor relationships
and earlier you've actually mentioned it
a few times but one example is earlier
when you're talking about the book
you're talking about influencers and I
mean selling that many books and itself
is a pretty cool feat and that came from
getting people to share and getting
influencers to help you guys out and I
know that you'd still do that with the
luggage so can you talk more about how
you've been able to get people to share
so much yeah I mean when you've done all
of these things to kind of create a
brand that people want to be associated
with it organically creates brand
ambassadors for you so kind of at a
higher level we have tons of celebrities
who have come to us inbound or have been
seen with our luggage we also have
celebrities who pay for their luggage
and you know it's been seen on everyone
from from Karlie Kloss to Adrien Brody
Jessica Alba and I think something that
we do is we look at who's actually using
our luggage or who's asking for it and
now we're thinking about you know now
we're in talks with them to to think
about ways we can partner and work
together instead of what a lot of other
brands do which is you know maybe throw
some money at a celebrity to to walk
around with your product when they don't
really give a about it but I think
the most important thing for us has
really been kind of our customers and
the other influencers be engagement he
talked about this earlier but we've
really created this culture in this
community that loves to travel takes
incredible photos and will photograph
their luggage in in some pretty like
unnatural situation like I think if you
look at some of these things I just
imagine whoever had take that picture
probably had to take it a million times
and then you know before they got the
right one but you know 99% of our
Instagram is user-generated which breeds
more amazing content and we've actually
seen the power of all of that influencer
and customer content and have two
full-time people on our team now
dedicated to just building those
relationships finding out when people
are going on these cool trips making
sure they have the latest luggage and
getting content back from them so it's
like a cycle that kind of continues to
fulfill itself great well you guys have
come a whole hell of a long way in 15
months now what's going to happen next
15 months or so um so we just wrote
raised a 20 million dollars in our
Series B funding so that's a total of
little over 30 million that we breathe
and one of the things we're going to do
with that surprisingly to a lot of
people is retail so last year we
launched pop-ups as data points in New
York London LA and Berlin and that gave
us a real sense of how and where and why
people want to interact with a way
offline I think a lot of people mistake
direct-to-consumer for online only but
the the physical experience and the
offline experience is a huge part of
what we're doing even though our luggage
is relatively affordable and has like a
high high quality to price ratio it's
something that people still want to see
and feel and and more importantly they
come to our store to interact with the
brand we have events and workshops and
classes and talks in all of our
locations and this year we're opening an
East Coast five Shakur West Coast
flagship is in New York and LA as all
stores in San Francisco Austin London
we're also expanding into a lot of
contents so right now we are just a one
product company but because we've built
this product in a really thoughtful way
people are asking for more from away and
want to want to hear more from us so
last month we launched a podcast called
airplane mode this this month we're
launching here magazine which will be
digital in print
in every way suitcase in specialty
stores there's a TV series in the works
so I think people have come to trust us
as a real travel brand and and are
looking for more things for us in that
sense pull any any final words you want
to say to the audience uh yeah I mean
these numbers I have been really
humbling and really exciting and you
know it's what you said the beginning
over a hundred thousand suitcases sold
20 million sales this time last year we
were like five or six people now we're
almost 70 so we've actually hired more
people since we made this slide last
week but I think you know you need to be
more than your product you need to focus
on what your product can enable people
to do we're not selling suits well we
are selling suitcases a lot of them but
we're selling travel and I think that's
the most important part and people you
know as we launch more products as we go
into media and content I think that's
you know at the core of it it's a
company for travelers made by other
travelers and our approach to building
our brand is we we approach brand
building the way you know luxury fashion
houses do but we run our company like a
lean tech startup and that coupled with
like our obsession with the customer and
the experience is what's really driven
our growth so far well thank you for
telling us the story yeah thank you
thanks guys
[Applause]